les traces de katrina sont encore bien
visibles à la nouvelle orléans
quarante quatre mille maisons
abandonnées
cent mille habitants qui ne sont jamais
revenus 1800 morts et une décennie plus
tard le souvenir de catherine et
douloureux jason freemen a vu beaucoup
d'amis et de voisins mourir en août 2005
des morts causées par le bris de
nombreuses digues comme celle ci oui des
maisons manque encore partout dit il
nous sommes dans l'horreur nine le
quartier le plus durement touché par
endroits c'est la nature qui a pris le
dessus
l'ex-policier stirling williams est né
ici il y avait dans cette maison dit il
une famille de quatre enfants nous avons
grandi tous ensemble mais après katrina
ils sont partis ce maisons sont délabrés
placardé affirme le rapport
elle travaille depuis sept ans à rebâtir
ce quartier qui a perdu 80% de sa
population
une tâche titanesque
cette montréalaise dirige lower ninth
dot orgue qui a reconstruit 75
résidences c'est frustrant et est juste
dit elle parce que nous n'avons pas
assez de ressources
plusieurs affirment que l'état et la
ville laisse lentement mourir ce secteur
il y encore beaucoup de racisme dans ce
pays
ce n'est pas par hasard ajoute elle si
le quartier le plus lent à se relever
est à majorité noire en 2010 amnesty
international a accusé les autorités de
priver des milliers de personnes de leur
droit fondamental au logement
le prix des habitations a bondi en
nouvelle orléans grâce à des programmes
dead
certains réussissent à se trouver un
toit ce couple attend depuis dix ans
pour acheter une maison
le prix 80 mille dollars mais ils ont dû
y mettre 350 heures de bénévolat des
libertés move dollars
beaucoup d'efforts pour une résidence où
le toro de passe dans la cour
le bruit ne me dérange pas je voulais un
terrain et j'en ai un à quelques coins
de rue de là le bruit des voitures cède
la place à la musique
nous sommes dans le village des
musiciens construit pour des musiciens
évacué après katrina un quartier où
vivent chanteur guitariste de pianiste
saxophoniste que l'on craignait exilé à
jamais sans leur retour
la nouvelle orléans perdait son âme
parmi eux
calvin johnson une vedette montante du
jazz et world music dit il nous a
toujours uni c'est notre héritage il
n'aurait jamais pu se payer une maison
et revenir à la nouvelle orléans
n'eut été de ce projet d'habitation à
prix abordable ce village est unique au
monde
c'est un succès
de l'autre côté de la rue demeurent art
johnson une légende du blues
content aussi de revenir à la maison
encore on maîtrise bien
on lui doit la chanson lorna une
complète du quartier emporté par les
eaux de l'eau qui par endroits est resté
jusqu'à un mois vit à auplata
il y avait de l'eau par dessus ma maison
s'est monté à plus de 5 mètres
cet immense barge s'est retrouvé sur son
terrain depuis une nouvelle digue a été
érigée construite dit on pour résister
mais kazan ont dit ce qu'ils cette digue
est devenu un ami un allié qui me
protège
mais ça prendra plus qu'un mur en béton
pour faire revivre leur nom
les commerces sont partis les écoles
sont encore fermées et les enfants n'ont
que la rue pour jour le quartier va
mourir d'ici dix ans affirme cet ex
président si on ne fait pas plus pour
l'aider mais pour d'autres secteurs de
la nouvelle orléans le souvenir de
katrina est déjà très loin
les restes de l'ouragan sont aujourd'hui
presque invisible pour les touristes la
ville du plaisir est encore en vie mais
derrière cette musique et cette
apparente joie de vivre
la nouvelle orléans cache mal une
souffrance qui refuse de disparaître